this man used to be my go-to interview
in the first few years of nfl total
access we would fire up bengal's camp
for him and it would be gold it would be
gold
jerry gold i tell you he is none other
than the one the only chad ocho cinco
here on the rich eisen show
chad it's been too long wouldn't you say
you know it it has been very long it's
been very long and i would like for us
to do something about that
okay what would you like to do in 2021
yes i need you and i
yes to either work together okay in some
capacity
to where we we get that relationship
again you and i
we were on a pace to be like the modern
day howard cosell
in muhammad ali like we were there we
were there we were at the mountaintop
you are correct
chad so um i have you know just
announced yesterday with westwood one
podcasting a new podcast shingle would
you like to do one together
chad you know i think we we need to do
that we need
not just you and i need to do that we
need to mend our relationship
but the world needs to
witness and be a part of that journey
that you and i once had okay so we could
call it uh
ochocinco and
uh zero or something like that what do
we do i don't know
um i don't know what we can but chad and
rich i don't know we
we could do something we got something
hey listen the the ideas
are are endless they are and i'm sure we
can we
we can have people we we can have people
come up with something that would be
you know that would be the best for both
of us
and it'd be pure content
gold so hold on a second
um chad before we get to that though i
think there is
something that um that is still
uh outstanding between the two of us
okay that needs to be addressed before
we move forward
even with this interview do you recall
the 2009 pro bowl
uh in south florida do you remember that
we were all in fort lauderdale florida
yeah you said at the time on live nfl
network television there is somewhere in
the archives of
nfl network the receipts if you will of
you saying
that you were going to send me a pair of
debo slippers
you were saying that in 2009 i told you
10 and a half
was my size and you said i'm going to
send them to you it's
almost 20 21 chad and i still don't have
them
uh what are we going to do about this we
can
we can resolve that issue very simply
because i believe if i'm not mistaken
you're in la right
i am so we're going to go get the devos
together
we're going to i'll pick you up we're
going to go to the slauson swap meet
we're going to go to the slaughter swap
beat and get you a 10 and a half
peridos now i'm not sure what your
favorite color is they have them in
black they have them in blue
they have them in red um
i'll go blue uh because you know uh i'm
a michigan guy and i like saying the
words go and blue next to each other
i'll go blue okay
um and uh and uh isn't there
a way to you know it's not that i want
to hang with you chad i would love to
um is there a way to ship them somewhere
supposedly i mean
i i think i think it'd be better instead
of shipping
we can make this a more more formal okay
you know have a conversation
coffee cigar talk catch up you know what
years and we can talk about the
development of a show that you and i can
do later on in the future and i think
that our
uber ride will be much better
rich and chad in the first ever episode
of whatever the hell they're going to do
together go
shopping for debos that rich has been
waiting for
for 12 years literally yeah yeah
literally chad i have a 12 year old i
have a 12 year old son that's almost as
old as me waiting for you to actually
give me what you told me you were going
to give me
almost i got you i got you i got you i
promise
what is going on and you're doing nfl
the grind stuff i
i love watching you do this show you
enjoy like are do you want to be part of
the paparazzi like full-time here chad
like is this what you want to do you're
co-hosting a show here you're doing
stuff for
nfl films i see i see you're you're part
of what's going on with madden
announcing who's rating is what i see
what you're up to i keep tabs on you
chad
yeah i mean i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying
it it's just something when the camera
is rolling despite my grandmother always
saying i have a face or radio
the fact that i'm able to to manipulate
the camera
you know regardless of whatever the
content is that i'm feeling filming
yes is pretty good and when the camera
is rolling i am gold i need no script
just put it in front of me give me some
talking points and i'm good to go
and i can just have a whole show by
myself with with literally nothing
speaking of which you once said that you
were if you ever made it to the super
bowl that you'd do the media day with
only a towel on but i didn't see that
when you when you made it with new
england is that because belichick would
have never let you do that
so what happened i mean listen it's one
thing playing
in that atmosphere and you know the
patriots don't play that there's a
there's a certain
mantra called the patriot way and when
you enter that building you can feel it
nobody has to tell you
it's just the way you you can just feel
it it's the aura the vibe the energy
it's a place of very very militant in a
sense i've never been to the army
never been to any of that stuff but if i
had to take a guess
what it's like and the discipline it
took you know where other people's lives
are in danger and you have to do
everything the right way
it would be playing with the patriots
but it was enjoyable because there was
one thing that was going to happen at
the end of the day
no matter what you were going to win
that definitely happened what do you
think is going on with brady right now
in tampa
where it you know because you just
mentioned how it was a very regimented
style in new england and obviously he
had 20 years of being involved in that
now he's in a new spot
you know what do you think is is
happening with this uh with this team
right now
and it's early yeah and people need to
understand this is brady's first year
uh off season pandemic not having the
time to jail build that chemistry with
receivers
off the lineman that stuff takes time so
what we're used to seeing with brady in
new england
is built over time and time and time
spent with different players coaching
staff everybody knowing each other
knowing what he does well
knowing his strength knowing his
weaknesses because we all have them no
matter how great we are
and i think what a year under their belt
and our off-season under their belt
as far as next year's concern we'll get
to see
the same old brady we've seen we've seen
flashes of his greatness and then we've
seen some of the bad side why are we
seeing some of the bad side
it's like getting in a new relationship
with someone at times
things don't go how they should because
you don't know each other that well yet
the time hasn't set in there's no level
of comfort because you're still getting
to know
each other the same thing with him in
tampa bay
and i guarantee you next year things
will be different why
because of the time they've been able to
put in not only this season but in the
off season preparing
for 2021. well the issue with that is
chad
is that you know the question is brady
might not have the time
that's the issue you know what i mean
like
he has the time he has the time he
remember the game of football has
nothing to do with age the game of it's
it's a mental game
it's 90 mental 10 physical he will be
fine
especially at the quarterback position
he'll be fine
who's the best mental receiver you've
ever been around
chad ooh a lot of them prob probably
who's masada
tj yeah you and tj was brilliant
you and tj and carson man you had it i
mean that was it right there man
it was beautiful it was beautiful but
that was it i mean you had it and then
you know chemo van olhofen you know came
right in and that was the end of
all of that yeah and i mean what a
bummer i mean you guys are really
worried
that was our year best year you ever
best team you ever were on right
would that be or maybe the patriot one
that you were i mean
that team was was unbelievable i mean
but it's like that all the time i was
more of a
a contributor in cincinnati during that
year
where we we played phenomenal
offensively and defense was
having takeaways galore right also
but yeah who's actually definitely the
bangles that yeah that was our year
who's the best receiver
today i mean you've gotta listen that's
a good one
that's a good one and the funny thing
i've been studying all of them even
before the season started you know your
top 10 your top five are normally
always the same based on production and
and targets that they get because
they're a huge part of their offense
and right now to me i like
i love devonte adams i love davonte
adams because he's consistent year in
the year out but
doesn't get the the the praise that he
should
from outside media and pundits that are
supposed to know the game extremely well
and uh there are some other great ones
you know um
i like keenan allen obviously you know
working with a rookie quarterback
this year due to uh tyrod going down
stefan diggs uh julio jones is still
there uh tyree kill
michael thomas you know even with the
ankle injury he's still capable of
putting up crazy numbers
things have been a little funny you know
with the saints this year but
i mean it's so many i can keep going and
the thing about when we talk about the
top receivers that i always like to
remind people
the top five of the top 10 i feel are
interchangeable
so it's based on who you like your
preference their style of play
and they can go on any team and be a
number one receiver
and they will still still be productive
deandre hopkins let me not leave him out
another one you know he's probably one a
one b when it comes to him and devonte
two
different styles of play but can get the
job done no matter what
especially d-hop he's done it with a
merry-go-round of quarterbacks
well you know and the crazy thing is too
uh with him
is you never have to wonder if he's
getting his feet down on the sideline or
in the back of the end zone
he has an uncanny ability to know where
he is you did leave one out and i know
i know you would but because you can't
name them all off the top of your head
but
what about what about dk metcalf oh yeah
dk is up there dk is up there but it's
i think it is dk's second year right
yep i think uh a little bit
great great great receiver but the guys
that i'm naming have been doing it
three and four plus years consistently
you know you know what i mean
and i think when dk puts together
another season
when they know you're coming when they
know you're good
when they know what you can do and what
you're capable of doing and you still
do it you still get it done you know and
that's what d-hop
has been able to do and stefan diggs and
michael thomas
and and these guys that i'm naming they
consistently do it a year and a year out
when you know what's coming
and dk only in a second promised
and his ceiling is super high super high
and i'm really happy for him i think
he's going to be in the ballpark to be
mentioned
with those guys that i just named in
another year
oh joe cinco here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the sports illustrated
awards we talked a little bit about with
richard jefferson
uh yesterday um so how many wardrobe
changes for you in this one chad what
are you gone
you know i just did one i just i just i
just just did one you know i'm known to
be
very fashionable yes i know very
inexpensive fashionable so i had on i
had on a suit
i got from target okay i got it to
target
but i got it hemmed and i got it altered
to make it look like it's something
italian and expensive but it's not
but it's not so i paid i paid i paid 40
bucks
okay off the rack got it tailored got a
nice turtleneck
20 bucks was on sale in target oh this
is a holiday sale so i got
got some good deals and i had everything
altered to fit
you know a very european fit and um
i mean it's good i look like money up
there but what people don't know
is my entire outfit was 65.29
well the good thing chad is uh you're
being economical there because you've
been
particularly generous lately as we're
seeing and
uh of you dropping off tips for
wait staffs uh that you come across uh
you've been
insanely generous there so it's good on
you chad ocho cinco
that's something i've always done and
the fact that i was so cheap throughout
the years obviously when i was playing
i really have all my money left over so
i'm not going to spin it so why not
bless those
that are working not only during these
times but just in general if people know
me throughout cincinnati and wherever
else i've traveled to
i've always been known to tip well just
because
you know just just want to be a blessing
in some sort
i miss you chad i'm not going to lie we
got to do this more often like literally
we spoke almost once a month during the
beginning of nfl network from 03 to
you know the rest of the decade i miss
talking to you i miss talking to you
it's been too long i'm here
my number's the same okay i mean my
number's the same i see it right down
here it does match the one that i had so
let's let's i'm not going to lose that
number and just
officially are you chad johnson official
like
in the state of uh like in the in a
government eyes like
okay so but we just i changed it back in
in 2010
but for some reason nobody says chad
nobody says chad johnson
everybody just says ocho they don't even
throw the sink on they just say ocho
okay
they just call me eight okay so that
that that has stuck with me for for a
while now why not
i mean why by the way the current ocho
cinco how good is he i know you did that
for the grind when you visited uh
carson up in idaho and you and yeah you
and he watched uh t higgins together
with burrow yeah
he's he's the real he's nice
he's he's nice and the fact that he's
just a rookie
the fact that he's just a rookie and
burrow is just a rookie
and they're picking up right where they
left off in college you know as far as
his poise and consistency
at the receiver position i had a chance
to talk with t he reached out to me
about some struggles earlier in the
season maybe week one or week two
about not winning the single coverage
battles
you know when everyone else was double
team when they were doubling doubling aj
green and they were doubling
uh boyd and i told him don't dance with
the line just go
just go pick a side dip his shoulder and
just go and beat him to
to the transition point and you're gonna
win every time and ever since that talk
is like he's just been out the roof ocho
uh i miss you man let's do this more
often i'll i'll reach out to you we'll
we'll stay in touch and uh i i look
forward to seeing you and your
target italian looking suit on uh on 20
or more streaming platforms uh tomorrow
for
the sports illustrated awards uh with
you and uh richard jefferson
on youtube twitch tick tock twitter and
more i look forward to seeing yeah
most definitely man i love you rich
listening i love you as well and anybody
else in there that can hear me
i love you too all right 10 and a half
that's what i'm telling you 10 and a
half
i got you in blue michigan blue that's
it thank you for the cats
thank you for that chad let's chat again
soon that's the one and only ocho
i do love that guy i miss him oh
look at that that looks like what why
wouldn't i want to walk around my house
in that
those look very comfortable i like
literally i'm just falling asleep just
looking at him
yeah when you brought up the debose my
first thought was
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here